البدايات لاشرف حكيمي الى يومنا هذا
نبداها معكم في منطقه غيتافي الاسبانيه
ولد النجم المغربي لاب وامن مغربيين
مهاجرين اسره فقيره تعتني بابنها الذي
يريد ان يصبح لاعب كره قدم رغم كل الشعب
الفقر لم يمنع حكيمي من هوايته التي دعمها
والداه ليصبح محترفا الاب والام ساهم في
بناء لاعب المستقبل بتجهيزه بكل ما يحتاجه
من اطقم واحذيه وغيرها البدايات دائما ما
تكون صعبه ولكن كان اللاعب ملفتا للنظر
لدرجه ان كشافي ريال مدريد اختاروه ليمثل
فريق الصغار لديهم ليكبر محققا معهم دوري
ابطال اوروبا وبين نوادي سابقه وانتر
ميلان ثم باريس سان جيرمان مع نجم اشرف
الذي كبر ليبدا حياته العاطفيه في سنه
2017 بل الارتباط بالاسبانيه لوسيا
اورتيرا لينفصل عنها ويتزوج بعد ذلك
بالممثله هبه عب وك التي تكبره ب 12 عاما
خمسه عوامل عاشها مع العب بوك ومع نهايه
كاس العالم بدات شائعات تلاقيهما التي
زادت مع تهمه الاغتصاب التي تلاحق حكيمي
في هذه الايام
[موسيقى]